let's Ark will be the one to reveal the
truthful Johnstone just as he has
promised he would in the very first
season and we know Ned is a man of his
word
that's a theory I'm bringing in this
video I know that it might sound
ridiculous at first but there are many
clothes hints and evidence supporting
his theory the showrunner decided to
reveal to us Jon Snow true identity in
the season 6 finale John is not Ned's
bastard but rather son of Lena stark and
rhaegar targaryen in the season 7 finale
on the other hand shall reveal Joshua
name and also finally confirmed that Jon
Snow is in fact illegitimate son Prince
Rhaegar and Lyanna as they were married
and his name is Aegon Targaryen he is
the true heir to the UH throne and his
Danny's nephew
however just still knows nothing and
therefore many fans are wondering how
Valjean learned truth regarding his show
lineage or in other words who will
reveal the truth to Jon Snow at the end
of last season John and Danny are
heading to Winterfell verse mm brainer
waiting for John to reveal him the truth
Semin brain telling John the truth is
too predictable and too simple to come
true at least in my opinion I definitely
see them trying to reveal to John but
something will most likely get under way
each time to try for example bran might
ask John to have a word with him in
private but then the horn will be blown
and the White Walkers are taking
Winterfell interrupting their
conversation I do expect something like
that to happen so howl just don't find
out who is she parents really are and
what his real name is this is something
that John will certainly find out
throughout the final season
that's not questionable but still the
question remains who will reel the
truthful Jon Snow
quite a long time ago I delivered you're
worried about Howland Reed in which I
brought you the possibility of his
appearance in the final season along
with the possibility of him being of a
huge importance in John's life as I
believe that he might be the one to
reveal John's real identity to John for
all of you that are wondering how could
how and Rebbie the chosen one to reveal
the truth Oh John let me introduce you
to Howland Reed and his important
singham's ruins with a few sentences
Howland Reed is the man whose children
Meera and Jojen played important role in
brain Starks life a man who saved net
from certain death save net Stark who
gave his best but couldn't stand chance
against her are today in superior
fighting skills the same man loyal
vessel how stark Howland Reed has played
very important role in star's life by
saving Ned from certain death is playing
a very important role because if not for
his children brain probably would not
even have become the three-eyed Raven he
would have probably been dead and will
doubtlessly play a huge role in the
final season considering that he is
among the few that on the truth about
Zhang Shuai identity pronounce about
John's parentage due to his ability of
having visions of the past and said
knows it from the books is red but
Howland Reed was actually there
Howland witness John's birth and there
is
why I don't see how Android not
appearing in the final season I
definitely see Holland having an
important role in this huge revelation
by just like Sam and brain I don't see
how and revealing to John either but
rather confirming it to him
sure Brent could share what he'd seen in
his vision or Sam could show him what
his red or even Howland Reed could tell
him the truth has he witnessed it
himself but the only way for the
revelation to have its full effect is
for John to discover it on his own
through the most important person in his
life Eddard Stark don't get me wrong
literal three-branch Sam and Holland or
at least some of them will definitely
play in poor role in this huge
revelation as I definitely see them
confirming to John the truth he will
find out where his father Ned Stark
Ned might not be his real father but Ned
will always be John's father he's the
one who raised him he's the one who
saved his life back to the question
having Ned Stark reveal John the truth
the truth that he kept through his whole
life as he promised he will to his dying
sister Lyanna when he's dead Bellavia
maternes has taught us anything
throughout his seven seasons since the
Ned Stark is man of his word if Ned made
promise he will keep it without a doubt
there's actually this one promise Ned
has yet to fulfill that might be dead
but it doesn't mean that he will not
fulfill its last promise and we did want
to reveal to show the Jon Snow the truth
which would Sam Brennan maybe even
Howland confirm this brings us to the
crypts of Winterfell the place for Ned
hit a hint or clue for Jon that will
reel to him his true parentage the
crypts have been included in both the
books and the show which along with all
the scenes that took place were there in
the show and we told Jon dreams and
visions about it in the books has led
many people to believe that there's
something about them of high
significance to the upcoming plot so the
net hid a hint for Jon and will Dwight
will find out the same hidden object
that was real to him that he's not Ned's
bastard but rather son of Lyanna stark
and rhaegar targaryen before I focus on
a possible object that Ned might have
hidden somewhere in the crypts let's see
what facts would have even led Ned to
hide it below interval the crypts are
mess even the larger than in Turkey so
complex about ground making the perfect
spot for something of a huge importance
to hide it as not only it would be hard
to find it but it's also the last place
someone would look for there are only a
few people that are visiting the crypts
which this scene from season 5 episode 4
is confirming as you can see while
visiting the stark family crypts beside
relighting the candle sense also picks
up the feather of the floor which is the
same fairy Robert Baratheon placed in
the hand of a statue of Leanna in the
very first episode of the series but as
being said it's easy to see why wouldn't
it have hidden something of a huge
importance in the crypts there's not
certainly a high possibility that net
took something wrong Tower of joy
something related to the truth about
parentage and hid it in the crypts but
if that truly did hide a hint for John
whether it's records widely popular
Harper Targaryen sword or something
entirely else how is it possible that no
one accidentally came up to it before
well he had it very well one would say
but if he hid it very well how is John
supposed to find it out a song of ice
and fire gave us a few hints regarding
this question in the books John has
recurring nightmares about mentoring
around the crypts in the very first
novel in Song of Ice and Fire while at
Castle black Jon Snow tell Sam that he
sometimes dreams of the crypts just says
that he knows he has to go down there so
he walks deeper into the crypts but is
afraid of what he will find within them
and awakens every time when the crypts
become too dark so dreams would most
likely lead John into crypts now let's
see which object Ned might have hidden
below interval manifests are assuming
that Johnny leader fine dark sister
black fire which are Valyrian steel
swords belonging to House Targaryen
Aegon the conquerer will did black fire
in battle during the war conquest while
later it was also builded by many of the
more marshal Targaryen Kings which would
soothe chant perfectly however black
fire was later given by Aegon the
unworthy to his bastard son daemon which
eventually removed sword from House
Targaryen possession as daemon fun in
his own lineage
house Blackfyre taking the name of the
sword the sword black fire remained in
the hands of each successive generation
of house Blackfyre until the line was
wiped out the source current owner and
location is unknown but it most
certainly is not hidden in the crypts of
Winterfell as its last known location
was not even Westeros dark sister on the
other hand belonged to Vizzini Targaryen
the sister wife of Aegon the Conqueror
the sword was allegedly lost during the
Blackfyre rebellion a most certainly is
near here and summer in the crypts even
though we might have already seen it in
series so John most certainly will not
find a lost again family stored in the
crypts of interval and it will not be an
object that will reel or confirm to John
his show parentage
so the question still remains what could
have net hidden in the crypts take into
account that an object is supposed to
reveal to Jon Snow issue parentage
should be regulars well known item
there's a high possibility that Ned
Stark he draggers widely popular harp
and it will eventually confirm to John
his show lineage regards harp might be
one of if not the only object that
Rhaegar could have left in the Tower of
joy with his beloved wife Lina Stark not
only didn't enjoy listening Rhaegar
playing her but he also most likely did
not carry his harp with him while
marching in the war let me also point
out that there has not been any mention
of Rhaegar sharp during or after
Robert's rebellion it might be implying
that Rhaegar beside leaving his best
friend and the greatest fighter the
Seven Kingdoms has ever seen to protect
Liana
their unborn son Rhaegar also most
likely left his harp and Liana in the
Tarot joy is a symbol for Liana of his
love towards her and promised to return
however upon rakers death during the
battle the Trident and upon Diana's
death in the hands of Ned at the Tower
of joy it's possible that Ned took
Gregor's sharp along with Lena's corpse
and hid it somewhere near Liana statue
in the crypts of interval if naturally
did high drag are sharp on the
Winterfell with intention for John to
find it someday where exactly did he
hide it as it somewhere nearly in a
statue
I place my bet on a tomb no one knew
existed it's John's own tomb as the best
Sir John is not supposed to get a tomb
of his own in the crypts so Ned would
have had one made for John in secret
we know that Ned had his empty tomb
already prepared before his death in
fact there are numerous empty and sealed
tombs repaired for not only Ned but also
for his children
in the book John often dreams of the
crypts of interval in which he sees the
statutes of Kings so Minter watching him
as he passes by them John sees the stone
star Kings eyes following him as they
tell him he doesn't belong there
which could imply that John is in fact
already given a place for his own in the
crypts additionally net has similar
dreams of the crypts as John which could
be a hint that he has angered the old
kings of winter by giving Jana please
even though he's not a stark but rather
a Targaryen
I believe that the tomb was prepared for
Johnny the crypts of interval hidden
away in the lower levels in there it
will be razor-sharp in the crown of
winter roses Reger laid on the in his
lap at the tourney at Harrenhal when he
crowned her queen of love and beauty
there might even be a letter written by
Ned Stark in which she states that if
John reads this it means that he's dead
and that he said that jealous issue of
this way imagine the chills we'd all get
seeing just me the crypts alluring truth
while hearing net worths or explaining
everything to John this way Ned would
also fulfill the last promise he has
ever given the next time we see each
other
I promise some of you might say that
having a two made for John with his real
aiming and Targaryen written on it would
make us such a big risk for it to take
as a stonemason could have told everyone
about it for all we know that did not
have to take any risk with this because
remember there is no literate stonemason
who taught you to read my father my lord
where is your father
is he alive who was he hey stonemason
stonemason who could read he taught
himself quite a man where did you learn
all this stuff about Visenya on earth
Valyrian steel sword my father was a
well-read stonemason can't say I've ever
met a literate stonemason in case you're
wondering didn't it have to keep John's
parentage a secret as he promised to his
sister the answer is yes Ned was
supposed to keep the secret from the
world not from John Snow which is why he
promised to tell me the truth once they
see each other again
Ned kept his promise to his sister
Lyanna he made Johnny's bastard son
sacrificing his honor and he raised him
as his own
Nate kept jeongsu parentage a secret he
did not tell anyone from his wife
Kathleen to King Robert the only reason
I did not tell the truth the JA himself
earlier is because he had to wait for
John to grow up in order to understand
things
in order to protect him not only would
it be difficult for Anna to explain to
young John why he has to keep his shoe
parentage a secret but it would also be
a difficult thing to explain how to
explain to a child that his father is
not his actual father how his aunt is
his mother and his grandfather killed
his other grandfather and uncle while he
also went into the war against his
actual father and grandfather and your
best friend killed his father his
grandfather has also been killed
there's also to explain how his uncle is
Aris and then Danny are exiled in Essos
and almost forgot he also had explained
to him how he is the true heir to the
Iron Throne but should forget about that
as your best friend would have him
killed if anyone finds out he's a
Targaryen
it's very complicated all in all Ned
Stark is an oath keeper he's a man of
his word and therefore I believe Ned
will fulfill the less promises given Ned
will talk with John about his matter
that will reel the truth for Jon Snow
through a letter that is sitting in
John's secret tune with his real name
written on it there will also be records
arpan leonis crown of intro
I might as well be overthinking and
brain or Sam will really to him instead
but it just seems too simple and too
predictable for such a huge revelation
to be revealed to join this way